What do I mean with parallel force? Let's think of Peter pulling his sister, Annie, in a cart.
He has his rope here, and it's connected to the cart,
and the rope actually makes an angle of 30°.
Well, let me give you some other information. The mass of the cart and Annie together is 25 kg.
The force that Peter is pulling with is 10 N.
And, I want to know if Peter pulls Annie for 15 m, how much work does he do.
Well, you might be tempted to say, well work, it's just force times distance.
He is pulling with a force of 10 N over a distance of 15 m.
Shouldn't that be 150 J? The answer is no.
We shouldn't be using this entire force of 10 N, just the parallel component.
Let me show you what I mean.
I'm going to have to erase Peter and Annie now because this drawing is just getting too cluttered.
Instead, Annie is going to become a box.
Peter is pulling with a force, we'll call Fp, and as always, there is going to be some normal force.
Now, I know the direction of motion of this car is going to be along the street, this way.
That means I want to break this force into components,
and this is something we know how to do.
Here, I've broken it into what we can call a parallel component
because this line is parallel to the direction of motion, and there's a perpendicular component,
and I remember that this angle is 30°.
Now, can you tell me if Peter pulls Annie for 15 m,
how much work does he do? Enter your answer here.